[Musik]
30 jahre deutsche einheit bei den feiern
sagt der bundespräsident es gebe noch
benachteiligung aber vor allem großen
zusammenhalt sind noch längst nicht so
weit wie wir sein sollten aber zugleich
sind wir viel weiter als wir denken
us-präsident im krankenhaus nach zams
corona infektion sprechen seine ärzte
von einer vorsichtsmaßnahme
und wenn fluten alles mit sich reißen in
frankreich und italien verursachen
unwetter immense schäden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesen
dreißigsten tag der einheit schön dass
sie dabei sind wir auch gut die zähne
für den sport hallo guten abend ein
riesiges bürgerfest waage plan tausende
gäste aus ganz europa hätten kommen
sollen
doch auch wenn wegen corona die große
einheitsfeier ausfällt die bedeutung des
tages bleibt sagt bundespräsident
steinmeier
der tag der einheit sei ein wichtiger
moment der freude der erinnerung und der
ermutigung aus potsdam katrin lindner
mitten in potsdam kein tag zum feiern
findet peter till kurz vor mauerfall
ließ ihn die ddr in den westen ausreisen
der musiker hat es damals nicht für
möglich dass deutschland wieder eins
wird das was ich nie gedacht habe als
als junger mensch dass uns das gelingt
ohne blutvergießen
das ist eine unglaubliche umstand 230
gäste sind geladen in die
metropolis-halle zum festakt der
deutschen einheit bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier fordert offen über
fehler und ungerechtigkeiten zu sprechen
wir haben vielleicht alle miteinander
unterschätzt wie langlebig manche
benachteiligungen sein können die dann
oft auch noch über generationen
weitergegeben worden sind und wir dürfen
nicht ruhen bis diese benachteiligungen
beseitigt sind wir miteinander lautet
das motto der einheitsfeier
bundesratspräsident dietmar woidke
wünscht sich dass das noch viel mehr
geliebt wird 30 jahre deutsche einheit
haben vor allem eines gezeigt richtig
gut sind wir in deutschland immer dann
wenn wir zusammenhalten ganz potsdam hat
sich herausgeputzt und schwarz-rot-gold
der weg des vereinten landes ist auf den
straßen nachzulesen und jeder hier ist
ein teil dieser geschichte 20
was ganz besonderes
weil sich eigentlich unser gesamtes
leben geändert hat bisschen fehlt noch
es ist immer noch ein unterschied
zwischen ost und west
wir konnten endlich reisen wohin wir
wollten und die welt stand uns offen
also auf veränderung täter ziel ist
wieder den osten zurückgegangen er
wünscht sich dass sich beide seiten mehr
zu hören dann sagt er gelänge auch alles
andere ein zdf spezial 30 jahre deutsche
einheit gibt es direkt im anschluss live
aus potsdam
zudem haben wir online zum beispiel die
große ost bilanz sie zeigt unterschiede
bei lhon alter oder auch
verkehrsanbindung zum durchscrollen in
der zdf- heute- app bei den
feierlichkeiten zur deutschen einheit
wird peinlich genau auf die masken
pflicht und abstand zwischen den
besuchern geachtet denn die zahl der neu
mit corona infizierten steigt auch bei
uns weiter an
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
wurden täglich 2090 neue infektionen
bekannt das sind 60 mehr als gestern
in den usa werden jeden tag mehr als
42.000 neue fälle registriert
der prominenteste ist seit gestern
doppelt der präsident ist mittlerweile
im krankenhaus eine vorsichtsmaßnahme
wie es heißt in seinem umfeld gibt es
weitere infektionen
möglicherweise wurde das virus bei
dieser veranstaltung vor einer woche
verbreitet im rosengarten des weißen
hauses auf abstand wurde kaum beachtet
nur wenige trugen masken peter jäger
berichtet eigentlich wollte der
präsident während seiner quarantäne im
weißen haus bleiben dann aber bringt ein
hubschrauber ihm doch ins
militärkrankenhaus nach maryland zuvor
eine kurze videobotschaft an die
amerikaner
ich gehe jetzt ins wollte reid
krankenhaus ich denke mir geht es sehr
gut aber wir wollen sicherstellen dass
die dinge gut ausgehen
eine reine vorsichtsmaßnahme betont das
weiße haus trump wird mit dem medikament
rehm die sie wir behandelt er habe kein
fieber und müsse nicht beatmet werden
sagt trumps bleib arzt
heute geht es dem präsidenten
gut es sind nun 72 stunden nach der
diagnose die erste woche und die tage
sieben bis zehn sind die kritischsten im
verlauf der krankheit 72 stunden in
denen trump offenbar von seiner
krankheit wusste dennoch ein spenden
event besuchte und in einem
telefoninterview angab er warte noch auf
das ergebnis
beobachter stellen die transparenz des
weißen hauses in frage auch ist immer
noch unklar wo sich trump angesteckt hat
in den fokus rückt die nominierung von
amy kunibert als richterin für den
supreme court am vergangenen samstag die
gäste ohne mindestabstand und masken
mindestens acht teilnehmer sind positiv
darunter auch toms ehemalige
wahlkampfchefin kelly ann conway
und der senator aus utah mike leigh vor
dem krankenhaus hoffen anhänger auf
trumps schnelle genesung und bei us
reportern macht die information einer
wohl seriösen quelle die runde
demnach soll es toll wenn den
vergangenen 24 stunden schlechter
gegangen sein als sein leibarzt
offiziell dargestellt hat vor einer
woche ist der jahrzehntealten konflikt
um berg-karabach neu entflammt auch
heute gab es wieder gefechte
armenien und aserbaidschan werfen der
jeweils anderen seite angriffe vor und
melden tote in step an erklärt der
hauptstadt der selbsternannten republik
im kaukasus wurden gebäude durch
bombardements der aserbaidschanischen
armee zerstört internationale bemühungen
um eine waffenruhe sind bisher
gescheitert
zurück nach deutschland und zur frage
wer wird neuer cdu chef
diese drei stehen als nachfolger von
annegret kramp karrenbauer zur wahl
armin laschet norbert röttgen und
friedrich merz alle drei aus nordrhein
westfalen da passt es dass sie heute bei
der jungen union in köln zu gast waren
gewählt wird im dezember auf dem
bundesparteitag peter böhme über drei
kandidaten auf stimmenfang
echte fründe stehen zusammen
karnevalsmusik heute in köln ein zug von
armin laschet aber es geht um konkurrenz
diesem union hatte die drei kandidaten
für den cdu bundesvorsitz eingeladen
alle drei betonten den kurs der mitte
wir brauchen in einer künftigen
bundesregierung die christlich soziale
die liberale und die wertkonservative
wurzel alles gehört zur cdu alles muss
integriert werden alles muss sichtbar
sein damit wir 35 bis 40 prozent nämlich
die große spanne einer volkspartei auch
wieder erreichen können
norbert röttgen der bisher als
außenseiter galt mit dem digitalen blick
nach vorn das ist der schlüssel der
modernisierung
das ist der schlüssel des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts
wir müssen uns vornehmen das was wir vor
30 jahren mit dem aufbau ost gestaltet
haben
wir brauchen heute einen digitalen
aufbau deutschland 20 25 als geht nicht
dass wir zurück hängen
friedrich merz forderte eine neue
generation in strategie der union wir
müssen im nächsten jahr in die
bundestagswahl gehen mit einem klaren
angebot an die junge generation mit
einem umfassenden begriff von
nachhaltigkeit nicht nur in der
umweltpolitik ja da auch dieses land
lebt zur zeit zu sehr in der gegenwart
und zu sehr auf kosten der jungen
generation
liebe freunde dafür erhält in den
längsten applaus der jungen
und mein persönlicher favorit ist für
mich friedrich merz einfach weil ich
glaube dass wir haben das schild auch in
seiner villa gut gebrauchen können
mein favorit ist ganz klar an laschet er
hat regierungserfahrung er hat charakter
norbert röttgen als besten muss man ganz
klar sagen wenn er hat eine vision er
den weitblick der bewegt in zukunft die
cdu im bund antwort kosten
es war eine schlimme nacht in
norditalien und südfrankreich sturm vor
allem aber gewaltige regenmengen
richteten zerstörungen an
es gab mindestens zwei tote noch werden
zahlreiche menschen vermisst die
rettungsarbeiten laufen luton leinhos
berichtete besonders schlimm wütete das
unwetter im hinterland von nizza an der
côte d'azur
teile des dorfes samatha vesubio
existieren nicht mehr
dort brachten die wassermassen häuser
und eine brücke zum einsturz
mehr als 100 gebäude wurden weggerissen
sind stark beschädigt oder komplett
abgeschnitten
der bürgermeister spricht von einer
katastrophe etliche dörfer sind nicht
mehr erreichbar
acht menschen werden noch immer vermisst
auch in angrenzenden gebieten italiens
richteten die fluten schlimme schäden an
17 vermisste meldet der zivilschutz
darunter vier deutsche
viele menschen mussten aus der luft
gerettet werden im ausland teil kam ein
feuerwehrmann ums leben
bis nach venedig war die
schlechtwetterfront zu spüren die neue
hochwasserschutzanlage mose absolvierte
ihren ersten praxistest erfolgreich mit
dem besonderen feiertag heute haben wir
begonnen jetzt kommen wir noch mal
darauf zurück auf eine deutsche einheit
in ihrer schönsten form
nicola albrecht
sie sind ein highlight am rande der
einheitsfeier in potsdam 30 porträts von
einer immer noch seltenen spezies ost
west paare denn gerade mal elf prozent
aller paare in deutschland sind so ein
gemischtes doppel fotos und kurze texte
geben einblick in ihre ganz private
einheit so auch in die von anne und
carsten sie sozialarbeiterin aus sachsen
er soziologe auf niedersachsen
die beiden haben sich erst vor kurzem in
werder an der havel kennengelernt und
das nicht ganz ohne vorurteile wie alle
zugeben muss bei carsten dachte ich
diese lautstärke wie der sprich zu volle
überzeugung und so wahnsinnig von sich
eingenommen das kann eigentlich nur ein
westdeutscher sein das wird in oc so
nicht machen
das ost west kategorien denken ablegen
daran arbeiten sie für die liebe aber
auch der gesellschaft hätte dass selbst
nach 30 jahren noch gut meinen anne und
carsten bleibt die frage wie
wiedervereinigt ist deutschland denn nun
eigentlich
wir sind voll wieder falsch also längst
auch politische regelung gibt zwischen
ost und west unterscheiden ist das
natürlich noch nicht ganz im lack würde
ich sagen
ihr persönlicher tipp wer es immer noch
nicht geschafft hat sollte sich endlich
auf die andere seite wagen um
festzustellen dass die klischees alle
nicht stimmen oder eben doch das hat er
auch mal gesagt zu mir ich hätte diesen
hang zum nacktsein das stimmt
eigentlich nicht doch es ist schön oder
jeden fall humor hilft manchmal auch mal
fußball schafft eine gewisse
leichtigkeit dritter spieltag in der
fußball bundesliga borussia dortmund hat
sich von den jüngsten niederlagen gut
erholt und feiert den zweiten saisonsieg
hier sind die ergebnisse deutlicher sieg
also gegen freiburg 4 0
frankfurt dreht hoffenheims führung noch
zum 2 1 köln gladbach 1 zu 3 bremen 1 0
gegen bielefeld stuttgart leverkusen
eins zu eins freitag union berlin gegen
mainz 4 zu 0 in der tabelle jetzt
frankfurt erster hoffenheim rutscht auf
vier hinter dortmund und augsburg bremen
fünfter in der zweiten tabellenhälfte
gladbach nach dem ersten sieg auf 10
bayern münchen mindestens bis morgen 12
ohne punkte köln mainz und schalke die
königsblauen aber mit der chance dass am
abend zu ändern bleibt sich schalke
nämlich im aktuellen sportstudio zu gast
deutschlands wm-hoffnung im profiboxen
atem
juni an nach dem sieg der deutschen
frauen handball nationalmannschaft gegen
die niederlande am donnerstag kann es
heute in lingen zum zweiten spiel gegen
denselben gegner diesmal gewannen die
weltmeisterinnen in oranien mit einem
sechs-tore-vorsprung 32 zu 26 gegen die
auswahl von bundestrainer
henk groener die em der frauen beginnt
anfang dezember nach alexander zverev
gestern abend ist heute auch laura
siegemund ins achtelfinale der french
open in paris eingezogen
die überraschung gelang allerdings
daniel als mayer aus kempen der 22
jährige qualifikant siegte in drei
sätzen gegen den an nummer sieben
gesetzten italiener matteo contini
daniel altmaier ist einfach nicht
aufzuhalten bei den french open auch die
nummer acht der welt matteo bettini
konnte den deutschen nicht stoppen für
den bau entscheiden dass ich wirklich
jeden punkt mit der höchstmöglichen
intensität spielen und das habe ich sehr
gut geschafft mit einhändiger rückhand
die an roger federer und stan wawrinka
erinnert der 22 jährige ist nach
langwierigen verletzungen endlich in der
lage ist ein großes potenzial
auszuschöpfen
2 7 6 und 6 4 im achtelfinale wartet der
spanier carrillo booster und das ist
dann am montag das war es vom sport
dankeschön
das wetter wird morgens zumindest in der
osthälfte freundlich im nordosten
anfangs noch schauer sonst von der see
bis zu den alpen viel sonne im westen
wechselnd oder stark bewölkt und etwas
regen starker südwestwind mit
stürmischen böen
höchstwerte 12 bis 21 grad
und auch in den nächsten tagen bleibt es
wechselhaft bei ähnlichen temperaturen
wir danken ihnen für ihr interesse